this video is brought to you by honey
[Music]
what's up guys helen here now here at
wisecrack we love our movie theaters the
huge screens the artery clogging popcorn
the neon 90s carpeting and the warm
welcome from maria menounos so now enjoy
your first look but the prognosis for
movie theaters lately has been uh not
great bob given the whole plague thing
that might feel like a no-brainer but it
turns out that these shortfalls have
actually been years in the making and no
one seems quite sure how to feel about
the whole thing with folks like director
james gunn championing the whole movie
experience while purists like
christopher nolan basically threatening
to burn the whole damn place down if his
movies aren't shown on a screen the size
of times square's eminem billboard so is
it time to start planning cinema's
funeral or have rumors of its demise
been greatly exaggerated let's find out
in this wisecrack edition are movie
theaters dead before we get into it i
want to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor honey now if there's something i
love more than eating a fresh tub of
popcorn while watching a new movie in a
theater full of strangers it's getting a
good deal and sometimes i can get just a
little obsessive with finding the
absolute best deals when shopping online
which is why honey has become an
absolute lifesaver honey is like a
magical best friend who hangs out in
your browser and waits patiently to help
you master the art of online shopping it
automatically scours the internet for
the best promo codes while you're
shopping i used to spend so much time
searching for discount codes on my own
only to enter them at checkout and find
out they were duds honey makes sure this
never happens again recently i've been
shopping for socks and i figured surely
there aren't deals available for stylish
foot sweaters but out of nowhere honey
dropped a promo code that saved me a ton
and now my sock collection takes up my
whole top drawer just saying and no
matter what you shop for online honey
already works for all the things you're
already buying and all the websites
you're already buying them on most
importantly it's just really really fun
to shop with honey every time i save
money it's like my magical fairy deals
mother was looking out for me and of
course more savings means more money to
use to find even more deals with honey
so sign up for honey for free by going
to
joinhoney.comwisecrack or by clicking
the link in the description and now back
to the show now we all know movie
theaters are suffering ticket sales fell
80 in 2020 the lowest tally recorded at
the box office for nearly 40 years it's
tempting to blame this entirely on the
pandemic and it's true that there's not
enough horse dewormer in the world to
keep cinemas from feeling the effects of
the coronavirus just kidding please
listen to the fda but anyway if you draw
back the curtains and look at the full
picture it's clear that movie theaters
have actually been in trouble for a
while 2017 and 2019 were the worst box
office years since 1995 and that's back
when the worst association most of us
had with corona was a mediocre beer
apologies to dom toretto and while
cinemas have been declining a whopping
200 streaming services have also been
fighting for our eyes now for those of
us who love movies the notion that our
local lowe's mc7000 drafthouse might be
empty by the time we're ready to return
is pretty galling we all have the sort
of vivid movie going memories that just
can't be created anywhere else i mean if
movie theaters didn't exist then tiffany
haddish would have never had that
life-altering experience she had while
gazing into nick cage's eyes as i was
achieving a um
momentous moment that i had never
experienced in my life
and i opened my eyes and the eyes of
nicholas cage are looking into my eyes
super big right and that's just not a
world i want to live in but our movie
theater is really at death's door
because as it turns out it wouldn't be
the first time we've heard that
particular song play it once them
for all time's sake here's what film
critic ao scott had to say the history
of cinema is in part an anthology of
premature obituaries sound color
television the suburbs the vcr the
internet they were all going to kill off
movie going and none succeeded cultural
forms and the social and private rituals
that sustain them have a way of
outlasting their funerals basically
people get upset just about every time a
new form of media comes around solemnly
declaring that it's killing off the real
art that they already had socrates was
famous amongst philosophy nerds at least
for denouncing this newfangled thing
called written language he believed that
it would have a corrupting influence on
young minds who would no longer have to
store every line of every epic poem in
their big ol ancient brains and later on
after togas had gone out of fashion and
radios had come in parents worried that
the hip news sounds coming through the
airwaves would distract kids from their
precious reading time we've even already
had a dress rehearsal for the great
streaming vs cinema's debate when
television first became popular it was
feared that no one would bother leaving
their house to see a movie anymore and
theaters responded swiftly introducing
gimmicks like smell-o-vision and 3d to
try to entice viewers back just as
modern cinemas are counting on imac
screens and 4dx showings to get people
in the door but while this might not be
a new fight it's a fight all the same
and shots have already been fired in
both directions see major theater chains
have traditionally insisted upon an
exclusive theatrical window of 90 days
because the chance to see a film right
away is a big part of their sales pitch
and they have defended this setup pretty
vigorously in the past you might
remember major chains refusing to show
films like the irishmen because netflix
wouldn't give them a clear run before
making it available for streaming and in
the past streaming services and studios
have mostly just taken this on the chin
in the manner of old joe pesci it's what
it is but more recently streaming and
studio giants have been taking a harder
line against theater chains universal
shifted streaming rights for blockbuster
films to kick in after only 31 days in
theaters with an even shorter theater
only window for smaller releases and
disney's done a mix of premium streaming
and theatrical release warner media's
decision to put all of its 2021
blockbusters on hbo max has seen
christopher nolan branded as the worst
streaming service while patty jenkins
said all the films that streaming
services are putting out look like fake
movies so it's safe to say that things
have gotten a little tense and part of
the reason for all this tension is that
many filmmakers genuinely believe that
theatrical experience is key to the
movie they want audiences to see like
denny villeneuve who made it clear that
he was not stoked about his epic space
worm drama dune going straight to hbo
max the way it happened i'm still not
happy frankly to watch dune on a
television the best way i can compare it
is to drive a speed boat in your bathtub
for me it's ridiculous it's a movie that
has been made as a tribute to the big
screen experience plenty of film goers
feel the same way too no matter how big
your tv is or how fancy a sound system
you're rocking it can't compare to the
scope and quality of a theatrical
viewing and that can make a big
difference for visual spectacles like
dune not to mention the in-cinema
benefits of more accurate aspect ratio
improved digital resolution or the
simple joy of seeing a film projected on
actual film reels but it's also about
more than screen size the thing that
really makes movie going such a sacred
experience for cinephiles is that it's a
communal activity that connects us with
others even if we're mostly just sitting
in silence as scholar jean matrie writes
each individual audience member is alone
by himself looking at the world
presented to him yet this isolation does
not separate the individual from the
group he does not communicate with his
fellows but he sees and feels with them
if not like them a kind of underlying
connection is established between
audience members shut up within their
own contemplation communication exists
at the level of feelings and fascination
it's why it's so satisfying to hear the
laughter of a full theater or feel
everyone collectively holding their
breath at the height of a horror scene
what's more seeing a film on the big
screen arguably creates a stronger
emotional relationship between the
viewer and the actors indeed when movie
theaters first began showing dramatic
films early audiences were captivated by
the closeness they felt to the new stars
far more so than they felt with
theatrical performers
as critic stephanie zakarik argues big
faces are just more evocative than those
viewed on a small screen she writes
scene large a great face is both map and
mirror a key to our own emotions to
those we may have buried or forgotten
but also perhaps to those we haven't yet
experienced i've often wondered if the
faces of actors aren't one of our best
means for fostering empathy it seems
possible that we feel a stronger
relationship with the character we saw
on the big screen than with one we saw
on our 13-inch laptops while
simultaneously playing candy crush and
doing laundry still not everyone is so
sold on the importance of seeing movies
at the theater director and man who
absolutely should not be allowed to
tweet ever james gunn was decidedly more
laid back about where people saw the
suicide squad he argued that movies
don't last because they're seen on the
big screen and used jaws as an example
there are now whole generations who have
only ever caught it on tv and it seems
to be doing just fine for gun a good
movie is a good movie no matter how you
see it the content matters not the
medium and even for self-proclaimed film
purists it's undeniable that streaming
services have their benefits convenience
is obvious cost matters too after
decades of chronic wage stagnation the
night of the movies just isn't nearly as
affordable for a lot of americans as it
used to be but streaming has also done a
lot to make cinema more broadly
accessible in other ways from people
with disabilities that make movie going
difficult or impossible to those who
live in smaller towns with limited
theatrical options the rise of netflix
and co can allow everyone to get in on
the zeitgeist at the same time and hey
this sounds an awful lot like the sort
of communal connection building
experience that movie theater lovers
champion and with so many people
physically geographically or
economically excluded from the movie
world when irl theaters are the only
option there's no denying that streaming
services have done a lot to democratize
the world of cinema still we think
there's hope for lovers of netflix and
chilling and movie theaters alike
because the truth is that the current
panic about cinemas is likely to be
another false death knell for the most
part anyway after so long cooped up at
home people are seriously missing the
big shared social experience the cinema
offers and once it's safe you'd expect
them to jump at the opportunity and
that's exactly what's happened in china
in january chinese theaters set a new
box office record for new year's day by
taking in 92 million dollars which was
almost double the previous record and
china's the world's biggest box office
so hollywood will likely be able to keep
the lights on a little while longer
based on that alone and there's every
reason to believe the industry will make
something like a full recovery in time
the elite number nerds at
pricewaterhousecoopers you know the
people who mostly correctly hand out the
envelopes at the oscars this is not a
joke moonlight has one best picture have
even predicted that the worldwide box
office could hit something like 42
billion dollars in 2024 and that
recovery will be bolstered by the fact
that many big chains are making an even
bigger effort to seduce film watchers
back into their arms by adding things
like digital concession ordering private
theater rentals and better loyalty
programs not to repeat ourselves is
there an echo in here but we've been
here before too
during the 1918 flu pandemic moving
picture world a major trade paper
recommended theaters take advantage of
their closures to apply soap and water
fresh paint and slick up a bit in order
that theaters may be fresh and clean to
welcome back the crowds who will surely
flock back to theaters eager to be
entertained which seems like a pretty
baseline standard for any public
gathering place but we digress
and it seems to have worked folks
definitely flocked back to the movies
after the 1918 pandemic ended it turns
out if you make cinemas nicer places to
be people are more likely to go there so
cinemas probably aren't going to die
anytime soon still the pandemic and the
changing world of entertainment have
recalibrated their place in society
rather than occupying the very center of
our popular culture as they did back in
the days of the empire strikes back or
even the phantom menace movie theaters
are now going to be widely accepted as
one option among others for watching a
movie for some they'll still be the only
true way to experience a movie for
others they'll remain a pricey
unnecessary or even unattainable
alternative to watching a netflix film
on the couch and for plenty in the
middle they'll be just one platform
amongst a litany of choices for when
they feel like staring at a screen but
what do you think wisecrack are we on
the brink of losing something sacred or
should scorsese and his buddies netflix
and chill the f out let us know what you
think in the comments thanks as always
to our patrons for all your support hit
that like button like it's going out of
business and don't forget to ring the
bell and as always thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you